let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling everybody involved
in this video from a publication called
the cut
which is i believe an offshoot or
property of new york magazine
the video is titled so what exactly are
white people superior
at and after setting up that straw man
it is
mostly an opportunity for a succession
of non-white people to air their
complaints against white people
complaints often based around degrading
stereotypes sometimes bizarre
stereotypes
stereotypes which lead me to suspect
that these individuals have never met
a white person in their entire lives um
i'm not just canceling the cut for this
by the way
and and and the bigots in the video that
we're going to play in a moment of
course i am canceling that but also
youtube for allowing it on their
platform and for permitting it to be
monetized
under normal circumstances i would have
no problem
with either of those things i would say
sure you know
this is ridiculous and uh and bigoted
but it's fine to have it on youtube
um the problem is that youtube would
never in a million years allow this
video in the reverse
to appear on their platform if it's a
free speech platform and they're
allowing whatever content fine
but this video in the reverse would not
be allowed on any platform
anywhere and certainly would not have
advertisers attached to it we all know
that so
all right let's uh let's get to it what
exactly are white people superior at oh
well according to television everything
white man could fly even a white woman
she could be four foot one
she knew karate she could take down 15
people okay let's stop it there for a
moment um
she says white people can fly in the
movies
yes those are superhero films are
referring to
nobody's claiming that white people
actually have this ability in real life
do you know what a superhero film is
did you think that the avengers is a
documentary
just because a white person could do
something in a film it doesn't mean that
the filmmakers are claiming that all
white people can do that thing when you
watch sherlock holmes
nobody's trying to say that all white
people are brilliant crime solvers in
fact
most of the other people in the movie
are also white and they can't do
what sherlock holmes can do i shouldn't
have to explain
any of this but here we are and this
gives you an idea of the mentality that
we're encountering here uh the mentality
of a person who thinks that
a white superhero flying on film is some
sort of
white supremacist statement it only gets
worse from here so
buckle up what are white people superior
at now i'm not going to make any rude
comments
about what you just witnessed there
because that's not like me
you know that and i think your arguments
don't have as much weight
um when you go for cheap shots i will
only say that
what you're witnessing here is the
torture killing of a straw man this is a
straw man being drawn and quartered
this would be a human rights violation
if it was happening to a real person but
it isn't and that's the point
they're pretending that there's some
prevalent view out there that white
people are superior
as it as if as if anyone's going around
making that argument
nobody's making that argument that's the
argument they want us to make
that's the case they wish they were
arguing against
but it isn't so instead they pretend it
is
and this is the result they they just
keep talking
mostly about their pets white people
love day dogs like that's
all you see cats letting them get on
your countertops while you're cooking
yes i get that you love your pet black
you need to take it everywhere
like everywhere i guess you know hey
emotional support animals i guess
i almost have some common ground here
because i also hate pets
but that's not a white thing emotional
support animals are not a white thing
that's a left-wing pampered entitled
urbanite thing
and that's the version of white person
that the people in this video are
attacking
i used to live in i just moved from
rural pennsylvania nobody in rural
pennsylvania has
emotional support animals i can tell you
that although my neighbor did have a
house pig
i'm not making that up they had an
actual pig that wouldn't that was
you know it would hang out in their
house some sometimes a pig would escape
and come onto our yard
um it wasn't an emotional support pig
though
i i i've been feeling if i had asked
them oh is this your emotional support
animal i would have gotten shot
so um no this is this is a particular
type of white person that they're
attacking the irony here is that
they are also all entitled pampered
left-wing urbanites
have you seen one person in this video
who doesn't have almond milk in their
refrigerator
have you seen one person who'd be out of
place at a at a you know an
extinction rebellion climate change
protest no
these are non-white liberals attacking
white liberals
that's what's happening here what
exactly are white people superior
men like making cereal casseroles what
kind of casserole
tuna it's always tuna what do you mean
it's always tuna
using mayonnaise in a lot of their
recipes
making bland food unseasoned chicken how
are you gonna start whole spice wars and
don't even use seasoning on your food i
mean come on
what exactly a white people superior
smelling funky
santa claus extreme water sports corn
mazes white people
are great at having fun that's a
function
of white supremacy because they just
don't have as many stresses
as we do white people are very superior
at their privilege
in utilizing it we do not have the
privilege to do
whatever and however we want to oh he
doesn't have privilege sure yeah he's
oppressed
he's a victim of white supremacy in fact
he's so scared of murderous white
supremacists
that he's appearing in a video published
by a major media company where the
entire point is to make fun of white
people for being frivolous foul-smelling
idiots
who don't know how to properly season
their food which again on that
on that score that's a criticism of the
kale chopping vegans
in their own social circles come down
here to tennessee you'll find plenty of
wonderfully seasoned
food often cooked by white people white
people who we should know
smell just fine okay let's get back to
it
what exactly are white people superior
insecurity pretending
fear being fearful of nothing being
ignorant
yes insecurity and fear right you are
you are literally appearing in a video
where the whole point is to denigrate
another race to make yourself feel
better
but they're the insecure ones okay then
letting their egos control their every
move privilege truly killing victimizers
playing the victim congratulating
themselves over that
they're incompetent at or that should
have already been done they're superior
at being
and now they're talking about egos yes
egos again i have to remind you
about the video that you are currently
appearing in a whole lot of ego here
so what exactly are white people
superior honey lying stealing and
cheating manipulation
withholding information lying telling
lies what kind of laws
uh the lies of history they say that
history is written by the victor
but the victor could be replaced by the
colonizer
what are white people superior at
conquering imperialism
imperialism colonizing colonizing
colonialism colonization
colonization they might be better at
that than us and everybody else really
they ballsy they rose up all over the
world and they walk into everybody's
house and says oh this is nice i'm gonna
take your sh
and they have no qualms about it they
can take anything baby
okay so they really did find a list of
every person
who's bought kombucha in manhattan in
the last month
take out all the white ones and invite
the rest to participate in this video
they were looking for an extremely
narrow perspective and they found it
what they found specifically is naked
bigotry hate and racism
these words are tossed around a lot
these days bigotry hate racism
but often they're lobbed at the wrong
targets here's an actual example if
anyone's wondering what
actual racists sound like when you roll
out the red carpet and invite them to
spill the racist beans
here it is this is it this is exactly
what it looks like
so what's the point of a video like this
why would new york magazine
put something like this out there they
turned off the comments on youtube for
for a reason they knew how it would be
received
if they actually did think there were
white supremacists
who needed to be debunked um
they knew that this video wasn't going
to achieve that it's not like this is
well-meaning but misguided like they
actually thought a nazi would watch this
and go wow you know what
i am terrible and i do smell bad and i
should expand my my casserole horizons a
bit
no this wasn't me this was meant
entirely to provoke
that was quite obviously its sole
intention that's it
but provoke what well provoke bigotry
hatred and racism
that after all is how you get bigotry
hatred and racism
they are self-replicating viruses
basically
if you want someone to be a racist just
be
racist towards them it may not work okay
you may not be able to provoke racism
out of everyone or even most people
especially in this country that way but
it's the best hope you have
so the idea here is to is to inflame
some of that white supremacist bigotry
which the likes of new york magazine
finds to be in such short supply
this has been the lefts and the media's
tactic for a long time now if there
isn't enough racism to suit your
political needs
you can first of all fake it you know
just take the jesse smilet approach
the hoax or you can be a bigot yourself
hoping to get some bigotry in return
this is called race hustling
race-baiting and it's far more insidious
than those terms make it sound it's it's
really quite evil
actually and so everybody involved
in this video is cancelled permanently
forever and always
may god have mercy on their souls
because they'll need it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content